so die fdp hatte gerade großen
bundesparteitag in berlin wo bei denen
heißt das ja gar nicht parteitag bei
denen heißt dass christian lindner
festspiele
ja ja es ist keine einfache situation
gerade für die fdp
sie ist nur eine von vier
oppositionsparteien und in den umfragen
aktuell die einzige einstellige
andererseits man muss auch mal sehen wo
die liberalen her kommen aus einem ganz
tiefen tal bewahren wir waren rocky wir
lagen blutend schwitzend stinkend am
boden dass niemand mehr was mit uns zu
tun haben wollte ja und daran hat sich
im wesentlichen auch nichts geändert
wir kleinen stinker ja seit die fdp
jamaika versenkt hat fragen sich alle
wie viel echter gestaltungswille ist
denn da bei denen man als partei vor
einer wahl wird mit schauen wir nicht
länger zu um dann nach der wahl doch
lieber zu zuschauen kann hat man ein
problem aber das kann man ja alles zu
kleistern mit feinstem fdp marketing
sprech das thema diversity ist uns
wichtig weil wir mit innovationen die
packen proporz in irgendwelchen
hinterzimmern genauso wie an unserem
female morning meeting special
relationship anstreben sollten
gehen sie mal in die social media
heerscharen von brückentechnologie aber
dem blog sein muss als erstes an bitcoin
denken und genau deswegen heißt
innovation nation eben auch in der base
nation innovation nation jüdischen
nation innovation
von den machern von the mood
inno welche nation geil was sie sich im
auslegen oder innovation nation das
offizielle parteitagsmotto beim
parteitag in berlin nicht durchgesetzt
hatten sich die vorschläge
organtransplantation nation akku
aufladen station nation und weil gerade
saison ist spargel plantation ist sehr
schade hätte für mich mehr sinn gemacht
immerhin arbeitet die fdp jetzt an ihrem
frauenproblem es gibt viel zu wenig
liberale frauen aber christian lindner
klingt fast so als wäre er stolz drauf
bei der fdp sind zwar gerade 22 prozent
wieso erklären sie sich dass es da doch
die partei nicht so attraktiv bis jetzt
ist
wir haben sogar bei den wählern weniger
frauen als männer
hut ab alter verdient lindner den frauen
übrigens wörtlich das ungehobene
potenzial der fdp glaube so was hört
jede frau gerne oder schatz du bist und
gehobenes potenzial
wieso kartoffeln tatsache ist tatsache
ist um wieder durchzustarten braucht die
fdp in dieser historischen situation
tatsächlich dringend mehr frauen
dringend meine damen und herren
man könnte auch sagen die fdp leidet
unter einem dramatischen niedrigen
ph-wert
jetzt ist aber auch gut dabei dabei
hatten die 1972 vor allen anderen
parteien die gleichberechtigung in ihrem
programm die liberal
lang ist's her ich suche eine neue
partei aber eine die auch regieren will
nicht so verbessern
alle elf minuten tritt wieder keine frau
in die fdp ein
ich fdp schippe nicht haben sie ein
problem
ansonsten und das hat mich verblüfft ist
die fdp neuerdings für europa das ging
aus diesem parteitag hervor sie sind
jetzt für europa was ganz lustig ist
weil die liberalen ja unter anderem
wegen zu viel europa jamaika haben
platzen lassen aber jetzt sind sie voll
die europäer und zwar nicht wegen
lindner nein die wirklich visionären
ideen in der fdp hat immer die drohne
will ich brenne für europa das ist auch
meine unterhaltung und heute ist dieser
funde auch christian immler höher
gesprungen
mit grüßen ganz genau
ach wie schön es ihnen auch die hohe
renschler
die drohne will schon allein wegen ihm
dürfen die bienen niemals aussterben
der fdp-parteitag von berlin hat uns
übrigens auch eine sehr aufgeregte
diskussion geschenkt dürfen ausländer
bei uns einfach so brötchen kaufen und
wie viel angst macht uns das haben sie
wahrscheinlich gelesen christian lindner
hat er in seiner rede seine bäckerei
anekdote erzählt und über die haben sich
anschließend viele journalisten
wahnsinnig echauffiert unser kulturchef
dietmar wischmeyer hingegen sagt das war
keine provokation das war kunst
[Musik]
christian lindner ausnahmepolitiker
künstler mehrfach begabung berühmt
geworden als fotodesigner hier sein
meisterwerk zum ende der jamaika
verhandlung es trägt den titel macht ihr
mal in st nun überrascht uns der
gereifte lindner mit einem schmalen
erzählungsband dunkle gesichter die auf
brötchen starren
es enthält nur die gleichnamige novelle
die handlung schnell erzählt der held
steht in der schlange beim bäcker und
wird zeuge wie ein zwielichtiger kunde
mit gebrochenem deutsch ein brötchen
bestellt
was will uns der junge autor david sagen
geht es hier wirklich um backwaren oder
doch um die urangst des weißen mannes
vor dem raub blonder frauen durch not
galli migranten hier filigranen
gekleideten alle brötchen metapher wir
wissen es nicht
wenn an ein völlig unverständlichen
deutschland brötchen bestellt kann das
auch rainer brüderle sein
das liegt daran das ist natürlich nicht
seine fdp hat immer schon zwischen
nützlichen und unnützen menschen
unterschieden unabhängig von der
hautfarbe man weiß halt nicht ob der
dreiste brötchen weckmann vor der
hochqualifizierte entwickler künstlicher
intelligenz aus indien ist oder
eigentlich einzig bei uns illegal
aufhalten oder höchstens geduldete
ausländer
kurz gesagt b ware hier nichts zu suchen
hat nimmt das erstlingswerk verzichtet
radikal auf spannungsbögen oder gar
planten
vielleicht lässt es sich aber lesen als
eine art handlungsanweisungen
wenn sie liebe zuschauer irgendwie
ausländisch aussehen
dann können sie bei uns nicht einfach so
zum bäcker gehen dann kriegen die
deutschen kunden natürlich angst ist ja
klar
mein tipp geben sie sich als nützlicher
ausländer zu erkennen oder noch besser
planen sie mit ihrem monatlichen
nettoeinkommen dann sind alle ihre
freunde
[Applaus]
es sei denn sie bestellt kriegt die
letzte nussecke sie zurück nach indien
menschenskinder was soll das
christian lindner ein spannender junger
autor den wir im auge behalten
bereits in vorbereitung sein erster
roman er trägt den titel hallo mädels
kommt ein blinder asylbewerber in ein
fischgeschäft bleiben sie gesund und
augen auf beim brötchenkauf
[Musik]